e siamo tornati con tanta felicità al
suo minimo al stoop lei mi dimentico
sempre che c'è il monitor che mi devi
stare calmi ma troppo calma forte non
devo prendermi infarti o se tu non paghi
la corrente continua bella tutti ragazzi
bevute questo video sono regine ci sono
tra di sua emili buon stu play una
favola sono le nove del mattino ben
chiaramente un arm e fa colazione alle 9
del mattino prendiamo un po di latte
infarti perché giustamente io mi ricordo
che c'era un tipo una volta eccolo
ciao ciao ciao io vorrei trovare la luce
a la vedono la luce fermento sento ho
sentito
sarà che brutto gioco ma che brutto
gioco regala che brutto fatal error pure
perché lasciato pure va bene anche il
computer non ha retto l'infarto è
cresciuto già aveva mi ha capito che
quando è buio devo prendere la torcia
subito perché se non la prendo subito
mi in groppa no ma se io non andassi di
qua ad esempio dove c'è il mostro ma
dall'altra parma queste chiusa perché mi
serve una tessera per passare al livello
successivo tessera che trovo non si sa
come equa a questo era proprio l'inizio
non posso uscire di mortacci mia
[ __ ] non pensavo mai ci fosse un
tizio all'inizio è quindi non torniamo
indietro
non possiamo andare avanti l'unico modo
è entrare qui bene dal e non riesco a
prendere la torcia e io non ci arrivo
paga non vedo niente
no non è possibile cinque minuti di
gioco tre infarti cinque minuti mai
successo onde ci mette pure tu che
qualunque per farti venire gli infarti
nei giochi detto lo devono che lo devono
intortare il jump schermo è qua no qua
anche se sai che arriva a te lo prendi
lo stesso perché non riesco a passare
tua madre morta dove sei lurida [ __ ]
c'è un tizio li ha se non stai ferma il
tg1 su quello che vuoi che ti metto in
quella scatola lì ti spedisco con le
poste italiane ha appena sentito poste
italiane sede materializza vorrei capi
novara ecco qua la porta è chiusa
dove trovo la tessera c'è giusto per
chiedere ci saranno scorsa una tazza
d'acqua in giro
scusate se sono in silenzio ma devo
capire queste scemo s'è materializzato
pure lui per il potere delle poste
italiane
eccolo cuore per constare sarà lo
stavamo il tipo schiacciate luridi che
peccato poi chiudere la porta per
cortesia grazie molto gentile e andare
di qua per forza l'unica strada permesso
gli serve la tessera numero 4 perché in
questo gioco non c'è l'audio c'è solo
quando ti saltano in bocca tessera nelle
altre mondizia che sarà nella scatola
tessera nella tessera non c'e la tessera
posso salire qui fondarvi la famiglia
noche del pane oria l'hamburger cioè
loro già ma cosa hanno ordinato a fare
qua ragazzi siamo tornati dove eravamo
in partenza e so che c'è un tipo che
gira quindi eviterei di stare qua troppo
vorrei vedere se per caso è spuntata una
tessera
che entra in trenta alloggi sono proprio
davanti al cesso posso cagarmi addosso
effettivamente perfetto o che gentile
grazie mi ha aperto la porta
credo che io debba venire di qua perché
specifiche ciò anzi un attimo
no no ridaje [ __ ] mai perché sto
giocando sta roba
porca vacca basta conoscere dove sono
non ci arriva fino qua o che peccato
vai veloce veloce raga non ho idea di
come non so come si torna indietro non
ne ho idea
ufficio i blog
porca prevede soccorrere sticazzi avrai
breve il livello 4 sono stato bravissimo
oggi preso 26 infarti però sono stato
bravo non ce l'ha il cotone
dell'elettricità potrei far tornare la
corrente forse un martello potresti
darglielo in testa agli altri ma non
prender non si sa mai va veramente o mio
dio
ora basta avere ansia giochiamo
normalmente tanto non succede niente
questo tranquillo
veloce come la vita veloce porca vacca
spegne spegne con satana proprio credo
ci sia una tessera stavolta sta solo
nella arrivare dall'altra parte a meno
che non correrà fino alla fine e non si
passò profico bene vieni segmenti brutta
lorda ho sbagliato mi sa che tutto qui
non ci dovevo venire perché c'è il tipo
che fa mm ma ci arriva fino a qua scusa
mi stavo una donna se ci arriva porca
vacca con il 6 in bolt lo fare tutto il
giro tutto anche dal tipo che dice mm
tutto il giro per donarli o che è
successo cambiato l'orario caso bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
veloce velocissimo sono tornato tutto
indiano ecco la black room che è aperta
perfetto ama era questa la porta va bene
ok questo allegro proposto in questo
rumore
dana che brutto suono cosa è successo
così madonna che posto brutto ma cos'è
no vabbè rega ma stiamo scherzando
questo mi fa troppo ridere non assenso
va bene raga basta però oggi non so come
si continui a questo punto ma va bene
così sono soddisfatto fatto tantissimo
più dell'altro episodio e non ci hanno
ridato neuro veramente ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto cosa se lasciato
momento mi piace anche la regione che mi
dà notizia nei secoli si rischia
telefono ci vediamo al prossimo visto da
ragazzi
[Musica]